Walli hey never thought we'd see each
other again eggs and omelets love and
extreme measures hey everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my legends of
tomorrow episode 15 video whole bunch of
flash whole bunch of Constantine and
there's all the Constantine season 4
stuff that we have to talk about too so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos they haven't formally announced
which shows have been canceled or
renewed but I'll talk about that at the
end of the video because I feel like
most of the fandom is on the same page
when it comes to stuff like that we're
gonna have so much magic stuff happening
in the DC Universe between Raven Titans
Trigon and Constantine on legends of
tomorrow there's just like a whole side
of the DC Universe and a bunch of
characters that they never got into but
I don't know which characters that
they'll have access to because Trigon
Titans is kind of like their premiere a
list title so they'll probably have
first pick when it comes to really cool
mystical characters but we can talk
about that when we learn more about
what's going out with Titans the reason
I think that Jesse quick guest-starred
during this episode is because they had
violent beam that was available between
filming other TV shows like she just
signed on to another TV show so she's
gonna be super busy I don't think she's
gonna be around that much during season
5 so I think they just wanted to get as
much Jessie quick in as possible while
she was briefly available for this small
amount of time so they're like okay why
don't you come on legends 2 because we
have all it west there it can be a nice
funny moment but it was a really quick
appearance where they crammed all this
character history backstory in comic
book Easter eggs in so the big comic
book stuff because I saw a lot of people
confused on Twitter when I was talking
about this when he's telling her off he
says I'm gonna find someone else and
fall in love with them what he's talking
about is Linda Park from the comics
because that's who Wally West got
married to in the comics so who knows
what the timeline of the flash TV show
is that they'll ever get to Wally West
and Linda Park on that but she dated
Barry so they've already changed the
comics quite a bit in the TV universe
but it's a big comic book Easter Egg but
the other really cool thing too is that
you get a lot of personal history
between the two of them that you never
got on the TV show so like you pick up
during season 3 and they're kind of
going out but you don't really get those
moments because you're busy following
Barry most of the time unfortunately
I can they're cute when Wally's talking
about meditating that's Wally West the
Zen speedster so they actually reference
this in the comics recently during the
flash war lead-up where Gorilla Grodd is
thinking about the difference between
Barry and Wally's connection to the
Speed Force Barry's more of a scientist
he has a more science-based
understanding of the Speed Force Wally
has a more spiritual understanding of
the Speed Force so it's a very different
type of connection so when Wally's
talking about all this meditations and
stuff like they saw him doing at the
beginning of the season that's what
that's a reference to in pretty much
anytime Constantine is on screen talking
about an adventure that he used to have
that doesn't involve having sex with
Sarah it's something that he either did
in the comics or something from
Constantine season one when it was on
NBC so I always get a lot of questions
about that the events of Constantine
season one were canonized inside the
arrowverse by arrow season 4 when
Constantine crossed over like this
sorted referencing stuff from
Constantine season 1 meaning that all
that happened within earth ones universe
but I think because we haven't seen him
a whole lot on the TV show they keep
referencing Astra like things that
everybody regrets just trying to get to
them so it's Mallis just messing with
their minds but I love the way that
Constantine double-bluffed him okay I'll
totally trade you Sarah's life for Astra
psyche can't free anybody from hell I
was wondering how powerful they were
gonna say that Mallis was because he was
strong enough to block Constantine spell
when they were trying to break into the
astral plane a lot of great jokes about
Constantine and Ava both sleeping with
Sarah you can kind of get a sense for
the energy of Constantine with the team
during season 4 during a lot of these
like he really picks the pace up when
they're all on-screen together what they
might be doing is as wall-e goes back to
the flash on a permanent basis during
season 5 of the flash and then during
next season two legends Constantine is
just the person that fills the hole left
by both halves of firestorm so there's
fewer characters that they have to worry
about which i think is good sometimes I
feel like there's too many characters on
legends and you get the extra budget for
the special effects necessary to do a
lot of Constantine spell weaving
john constantine you dare into my realm
we got to see sarah wearing her Black
Canary costume again still the
coolest-looking Black Canary costume
that we've ever had in the arrowverse
still like the leather jacket blonde wig
better like she's the closest we ever
had to a real Black Canary but all in
all pretty solid episodes we even got to
see Commander Steele from the Justice
Society come back for like a really
brief scene I'm really upset that they
haven't tried to do more with the
Justice Society but I'm also kind of
upset that they didn't just do a Justice
Society TV show instead of doing legends
of tomorrow
I think Warner Brothers has some sort of
moratorium on using big names like that
like JSA or justice or anything that's
not in the animated universe speaking of
Young Justice season 3 there'll be
plenty of that coming up later this year
start talking I felt like the heatwave
fire totem moment at the end worked it
would make sense that being somebody
connected to fire so much he would wield
the fire totem at some point see doesn't
work
he still is mEEMIC part of me even
wondered if most of the legends would be
the ones to wield the totems but NORAD
Ark is still a bit of a question mark
like I still feel like there's something
inside her they're gonna try and turn
like they have that whole arc with Rey
where he's kind of into her so they're
trying to imply some sort of chemistry
between the two of them even though
they're focusing more on the Sarah
Ava relationship stuff the whole thing
about Dungeons & Dragons at the end
inviting Constantine to join their
adventure party I feel like is a bit of
an Easter Egg for him coming on the ship
during season 4 becoming a series
regular are you prepared to join us on
this mission most deadly
[Music]
well tonight's choir I'm all yours but
the really important thing about that is
that like they made this big
announcement Constantine joins the
legends of tomorrow as a regular during
season four the CW network has not
formally renewed any of the TV shows
even though they're like yeah you know
we're pretty confident everybody's gonna
get another season the producers have
said the same thing the CW has still not
issued a formal statement I could
probably spend 20 minutes talking about
output deals and how the CW makes its
money on its TV shows and why ratings
aren't as big of a deal but I think
bare-minimum arrow gets one more season
and Supergirl and legends make it to
season five and in the flash just
depending on what ratings are like in a
couple years continues through season
seven eight nine who knows about season
ten way too early to talk about stuff
like that but they're never gonna cancel
the flash so don't worry about that
but when they do make that formal
announcement I'll make a video for that
so no worries
but everybody let me know what was your
favorite part of the episode and what do
you think the big twist with them
fighting Mallis is going to be they had
the whole metaphor about the Dungeons &
Dragons six swords they're gonna need
all of them to bind Mallis which means
that they will have to turn Nora if
they're gonna do that because it feels
like she's gonna continue to be a totem
bear right up to the finale but if you
guys didn't know the flash is on break
arrow is on break for the next couple of
weeks but I'll be doing bonus videos so
leave your requests for what you want my
flash bonus video this week to be about
I'll name a new giveaway winner when I
post that flash video tomorrow there's
also some new Rick and Morty season four
that I'm working on so all that will
post tomorrow click here for brand new
flash Godspeed and click here for brand
new Avengers infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight